jumping into a new subject called
Battlestar Galactica can you talk about
the history in terms of how you got that
thing off the ground wait you know back
in the early 2000s how it all came
together yeah I got a call from David
Icke who was a he used to be a studio
Network executive who had become a
producer on the universal lot and I had
known him from another project David
Icke called me and I think January or
February 2002 and said hey I'm gonna
have to steal Universal and they're
looking for somebody to come in with a
new take on Battlestar Galactica
are you interested I said huh maybe let
me think about it you know I was in
space for a long time and I'd gotten out
of space and I didn't know if I wanted
to go back into it but I hadn't watched
it a very long time so I tracked down
the pilot at Blockbuster and rented it
on VHS and watched it over a weekend and
that viewing kind of I had an epiphany I
maybe because that was just a couple of
months after the 9/11 attacks and so I'm
watching the original Battlestar in that
context and I realized immediately that
if you redid that show at that moment in
time it would have a whole different
resonance for the audience you know the
idea of an apocalyptic attack from your
enemies and you know destroying the
human race and then it's about the
survivors who are running away and
pursued by their by their enemies into
the night that's a completely different
show than it was in 1978 and it was an
opportunity to really comment on the
time that we were in and talk about
things that were current in American and
society and in the world and freedom
versus security and the nature of
terrorism and all kinds of stuff and I
just got excited by it and this called
him on Monday said ok yeah let's do I
think there's some there's really
something cool here that we could do
that show I remember watching it as it
aired and it had so much buzz around it
and it was it was in the cultural
zeitgeist for you know as it was going
on with some it was a really big thing
can you sort of talk about what it was
like making that show with the buzz
around it and you know the critical
acclaim and you know what I mean yeah I
mean it's interesting because we got it
I think that the critical acclaim came
first you know the the ratings were
the ratings of the miniseries were very
good and they were good enough to get us
going to series but then the ratings
were sort of for sci-fi channels metrics
at the time but we were kind of on the
bubble all season one but there was
started become this buzz and critics
especially were really supportive of the
show and there came this buzz that was
getting around the show and we started
getting awards and we were in the FI
list and we won the Peabody Award and it
was like we got all this sort of acclaim
and but the ratings were okay like
sci-fi channel always made a sweat every
pickup like they might cancel the show
or they are you know they're gonna cut
it they're gonna pick up the show but
they're gonna cut our budgets you know
it was that kind of conversation so we
always were sort of fighting in the
sense of we could be cancelled at any
moment but we really believe we're those
true believers and what we're doing here
and again like deep space 9 we were like
squad day they'll love us one day this
will be that special show that they'll
all talk about but but right then it was
hard to feel it you know you did start
to see it grow over the course of the
series you know the first hour first
Comic Con that I went to with the cast
before the show would actually broadcast
there was a lot of skepticism in the
room there wasn't a full house by any
means we went out on to the floor of
Comic Con to sign autographs me and if
just like three or four the cast members
and people kind of came up and they were
like you're redoing Battlestar Galactica
why yeah it's okay it's gonna be cool
you're gonna trust me they're like some
people just took the signature didn't
know why they were taking the signature
the second year suddenly the it was a
packed house and then then the third
year through and we had to get a bigger
room and it was like mayhem and
craziness and we were rock stars and it
was like you just literally saw it take
off over the course of those three
comic-con so there was and you really
had the sense of something special by
then and by the time the show ended the
network had changed its tune even though
the ratings were still never spectacular
by their lights they were like starting
to regret that we were ending the show
and they were putting they were I would
go into the executives offices and they
were hanging up the awards that the show
won in their offices when they used to
just like say ah nobody cares about
those awards or the ratings our rings
aren't that good that's not really what
matters it's so funny because Battlestar
when you went to
Comic Con that was before Comic Con had
really transitioned into you know now
it's the Comic Con everyone knows but
back then a show could be in one of
those small rooms you know and it well
you know I remember I'm gonna I'm gonna
date myself but I remember the first
time that Smallville went to comic-con
and you know it had like no but it was
in a small little room that old maybe
200 people you know and it was different
it was still a large gathering but
you're right the culture of it was very
different I remember the moment I
thought the comic-con change was when I
walked down the floor one year and there
was a booth for the office and I was
like the office that has no there's
nothing's onra about the office at all
it's a fantastic show but the moment
that it was like oh this is all gonna
change cuz they've all woke up to the
fact that this is a huge marketing
opportunity right here and sure enough
from that point forward it was just like
all bets are off it's just like
everybody we started going to comic-con
completely what was it like in the
writers room and making the show because
as you mentioned with sci-fi I mean you
you were making the show and this is
gonna be an understanding a sarcastic
thing but you were making it for $5.00
and a roll of duct tape an episode you
know you you you didn't exactly have
these crazy budgets to make that show so
I'm curious what is it like writing when
you know the limits you have limitations
with the budget and even though you have
these lofty ideas and this big story
telling you want to do you know you're
you're you're sort of trapped by that
budget well fortunately going into it I
kind of knew that was gonna be the case
so I sort of set up the miniseries as an
excuse to build all the standing sets
that we were gonna need for the show so
we pretty much built most if not all the
galactica for the miniseries so now we
had standing sets and then I told the
writers from the beginning that it was
really a character story that was it was
about the characters it's about the
characters is about the characters and
because it's about the characters you
could just do scenes of them talking in
rooms and that's really what the
lifeblood of the show was gonna be it
was gonna be about them as people and
then we could kind of pick our battles
so when we were gonna go outside and we
were gonna have space battles and how
many other ships we could see and you
know what the
locations were gonna be but that the
bread and butter of the show was Adama
and Tigh walking down a corridor to
having a conversation or Starbuck and
Apollo you know in a conflict on the
hangar deck on our standing set so we
really we felt the pinch and there were
definitely times and we were cursing the
our lack of budget but the show was
designed in part to take advantage of
the fact that I wanted it to be a
character piece first and foremost and
that's mostly just people talking when
when did you I'm curious about like the
the ultimate arc of the series did you
know early on where you all where you
wanted it to go did you always know you
wanted to be a certain amount of seasons
or how much was it you you know you
pitched that idea and then it was
figuring it out as you were going
I was admin on we're just gonna figure
it out along the way I said you know at
the beginning I could think about ten
episodes ahead was my metric and I
intend episodes I want to be here all
right now it's let's Ark those out then
we'd catch having okay what in 10 more
episodes were gonna be over here and
then we dark that out but I had no
preset idea about how many seasons it
would be whether they would find earth
what earth meant what the finale was
gonna be I just wanted it to be a very
organic thing and improvisational and
you know I think the show thrived on
that kind of an improvisational quality
because there were notions I had about
the show at the beginning that
ultimately proved not to be that great
and that we found better ideas along the
way and the characters evolved along the
way and the story evolved along the way
and a lot of things would not have
happened if we had had like a preset
locked and you know written and stone
kind of idea what the series was now you
know there's a downside to that too you
improvisationally is fine but at a
certain point you've created so much web
of mythology that you have to knit it
all back together or now all has to
makes sense and that becomes a challenge
you push it now we've got all these plot
threads that we've thrown up and we do
have to find ways to knit them back
together and make something coherent
going forward but at that time I thought
that was a trade-off worth making and it
still felt to this day I know that
there's some of the best things that
came out of the show were there because
we were willing to just change our minds
and we were willing to just throw things
out and pull something else in and
always look for the best idea in the
room
Arlis of where we thought we were going
let's go here instead because that
sounds that sounds better when you
finally realized it's gonna end I
believe you guys did like a three-part
series finale what how sort of talk
about crafting that finale I thought it
was like I loved the series finale the
last episode and I'm just curious how it
all came together in terms of you know
what I mean like where did the idea come
from
and also was it ever almost something
else well it was I mean leading up into
the final season we took a writer's
retreat for about a week and all the
writers went to Lake Tahoe and we read
some cabins and stuck stay with each
other we just brainstormed what the
final year was going to be and out of
that process came generally probably the
first half of the season and then we had
a whole separate second half of the
season and what developed is add again
as we went and started writing those
initial scripts and started working out
the character arcs and the stories we
started to realize that the second half
of the season wasn't lining up as well
we had changed a lot of things and it
didn't feel as satisfying so we had to
go back we went in back in a couple of
times just in terms of what the
destination was where we were generally
trying to go by the end but we didn't
actually break the final the final
episode until relatively late in the
season so we had a guidepost of sort of
where we wanted that to be and generally
what was gonna happen in the finale but
we didn't really break it in detail
until it was time to write it and then
it was sitting in the room like
traditionally and trying to figure it
all out and became the first couple of
sessions were very frustrating and we
all got frustrated it was just too much
plot and there was so much action and it
was just like trying to wrap up all
these war stories and do this big war
thing and I went home one night and and
the shower just had this epiphany and it
came back in the next day and raced the
board just wrote it's the characters
stupid on it and we all laughed and it
was let's just talk about the characters
and let's just talk about each of our
characters and what we want to do with
them in the finale and I wrote I mean
one of the first images I had was
somebody has a broom chasing a bird
around inside of a house and I don't
know what it means and I don't know who
that is
is but let's put that and we put that up
on a card and smacked it on the board
and we just started building these
pieces of character moments and then we
started figuring out who the character
which characters we were going to visit
and then we started talking about seeing
parts of their backstory that we had
never seen and feathering that into a
big wrap-up and a big love letter to the
show and who the characters were and who
they had been and how they had become
the people that we knew seemed like a
very that that would be a great idea for
the for the final episode and that's how
the final episode kind of ultimately
took its shape I believe when it aired
the three parts were like a hundred and
forty-one minutes there's an extended
cut that was 152 and I've read that the
original uncut was like four hours or
something crazy am I wrong about this
probably true I mean you have to
remember it was never it was going to be
originally a two-hour and it was written
as a two-hour but the page count and
then the amount of time that was shoot
once we started putting the footage
together it was clear it was never gonna
fit in a two hour time slot so then you
started talking about well how do we do
that there's no such thing it's not
really a three hour movie that's too big
especially for sci-fi channel it's
asking too much of the audience with
commercials and so it became well how do
we divide this up maybe it's a three
parter so it became just sort of what do
we do with all the foot how do we make
this coherent and then they went for
okay what do as a three part broadcast
there the original cut probably was
closer to four hours there was a
different structure in the script than
what ended up on-screen the structure
and the script was much less Linear's
very nonlinear I was doing flashbacks
and current stuff mixing up the
flashbacks you know you would see the
end of Laura's story before you saw the
beginning of it and then you'd come back
to the present then you'd see another
piece of a Damas story and it was really
like very challenging when you read it
it was like wow it was really a huge
thing to wrap your mind around it was
very cool and everyone got really
excited about it
when you laid it out like that infinite
know it was really part and as much as I
wanted it to work I kind of people were
around me
I don't know I'm not sure it works maybe
you should make it linear and then I
started failing okay maybe you're right
so it just became a more linear piece in
that all the flashbacks lined up one two
three or four or five you know
chronologically instead of doing all the
flashbacks out of order so once you did
that
it changed the fundamental structure of
the entire and then but just there were
some things that work some scenes going
too long so that's what the difference
between the 4-hour and the 3-hour was
was really just kind of changing the
structure tightening up and making the
usual cut cuts and edits you do on
almost any piece of film to just get it
down to its to its fighting weight have
you ever shown the uncut version has it
have fans ever seen it have you ever
just talked about showing it like
comic-con as like you know the uncut
series finale I have not and I frankly
haven't seen it myself since that
initial viewing I mean I probably have
it on a burned on a DVD someplace
somehow I'm sure if I asked Universal
where they're their masters are they'd
say oh yeah we have it all the masters
in a salt mine somewhere and then they'd
never build find them but it's play you
know it exists it was put together that
way and it would be fun to watch it
again I don't know you know there's also
a version of the miniseries that was
never seen to that was much longer and
you know had but a lot of times longer
is not better there's tricks you know
we're used I'm used to watching original
directors cuts and early cuts of
episodes and movies and they're always
long but that doesn't mean that they're
better they just have more stuff and
some of that stuff just needs to go
because it's it's not working the jokes
not playing it's it's unnecessary it's
repetitive so a lot of the editing of
these things is really to its betterment
but that said I wouldn't mind I may be
kind of a coot to find the original cut
and take a look at it well what I'm
curious about is so you have that for
our cut of it how much in that cut do
you think was unfinished like is it one
of these things were like you could
actually watch it and enjoy it or you're
gonna see a lot of storyboards or some
green screen do you know what I mean oh
you would see you wouldn't see
storyboards you would probably see a lot
of green screen and you would see in
terms of the
like the Vipers and Battlestar fighting
stuff there might be temporary shots it
could be previous shots which kind of
gray scale models there could be missing
your shots you know just cards that say
what's up gonna happen in this show it
would be really rough you know very
rough stuff it wouldn't it's not
wouldn't be close to you know a finished
product